in our other top story tonight the
countdown is on
and nearly down to zero for the grand
opening of las vegas newest resort it's
incredible resorts world
opening to the public tomorrow night and
today eight news now got a peek
inside for the very first time orc omana
joins us live near the property
taking a closer look orco
well brian in just 24 hours resorts
world will open its doors to guests
it's the first new resort on the las
vegas strip in more than a decade it
boasts more than 3
thousand rooms and suites as well as a 5
000
seat theater that'll be home to big name
residencies such as celine dion
katy perry and luke bryan today we got
our first look inside
nobody in the country has what we have
take a step inside resorts world and
you'll find
it's out of this world let's start at
its 117 thousand square foot casino
there's cashless wagering through the
resorts world app you'll buy
in and he'll scan it and show a qr code
to get your chips executives say it's
what sets this las vegas strip property
apart
bring back the classic vegas service
that you have or we've come to to know
and miss
but do it with today's technology unique
is also the perfect way to describe
resort's world's nine pools
and its bars and restaurants here i am
this chef from the philippines famous
for her roasted pig known as let john
was invited to open up shop here
because resorts world staff remembered
her cooking from decades ago
now she's part of history when you say
las vegas wow i couldn't believe it i'm
just so
thankful to be blessed with this
opportunity that same excitement felt
around the resort from this texas-style
barbecue joint
it's awesome honestly to be nestled here
with a lot of like global
legends to this classic cocktail lounge
we have an amazing space we've worked
really hard
to get the place open we have something
wonderful to offer everyone is gearing
up
for a good time we're super excited to
be here it's
after everything that we've gone through
it's great that vegas is opening up a
new
building now the ribbon cutting for
resorts world's grand opening is set to
take place tomorrow around 6 30 p.m
the public can enter starting at 11 and
it's safe to say we can expect
a pretty big crowd eight news now will
be there all evening to bring you
coverage so stay with us
for all the excitement reporting live
tonight orco mana 8 news now